[Música]
ah
pierden el sabor de la infancia sé que
cuando lo sentís te traslada al lugar
donde creciste para mí ese sabor es la
torta de manzanas de mi abuela cada vez
que yo venía a casa trae el sudor de
manzanillo corrí a agarrar una porción a
veces antes de saludarle
hace tiempo mi abuela falleció y cuando
estábamos ordenando sus cosas con mi
hermano encontramos escrita con su letra
la receta de la torta de manzanas ese
mismo día nos pusimos a hacerla y cuando
abrimos el horno nos miramos sonreímos
se veía igual pero cuando lo probamos no
tenía el mismo sabor
intentamos varias veces más pero el
sabor exacto se nos había escapando ser
que estábamos haciendo algo mal
mi abuela sobre olvido de notar algo
importante de la receta
en ciencia particularmente en psicología
está pasando algo parecido lo que
estamos tratando de hacer tortas de
manzana sino que hay recetas que parece
que no están funcionando
y estudios que buscan entender cómo nos
comportamos de forma general sabiendo
que la historia y la cultura influyen
pero asumiendo que hay factores comunes
a la mayoría de las personas
esos estudios tienen un componente
fundamental un requisito fundamental y
es que tienen que ser repetibles es
decir que un estudio afirma que un
fenómeno ocurre de manera general si
otras personas hacen el mismo estudio
deben encontrar los mismos resultados
necesitamos tener y seguir una receta
porque sólo así podemos diferenciar los
fenómenos generales de hallazgos locales
o que se deban a la casualidad y esto no
tiene que ver con satisfacer nuestra
curiosidad sino con entender el mundo
para mejorar nuestra calidad de vida
hace poco en el laboratorio donde
trabajo decidimos repetir una estudio
pero surge un problema a pesar de que el
artículo publicado en la revista
científica explicaba cómo le habían
hecho me estaba toda la información
escribimos a los autores pero
respondieron que habían perdido todo
todos los materiales y todos y no se
acordaban nada
siguiendo lo que estaba escrito en el
artículo repetimos el experimento pero
no obtuvimos los mismos resultados
será que hicimos algo mal o habrá algo
mal en la receta
el tema es que nuestro no fue un caso
aislado alrededor del 2012
investigadores e investigadores en
distintas partes del mundo colaboraron
para repetir estudios de psicología
publicados en revistas muy prestigiosas
que pasó menos de la mitad dieron los
mismos resultados
y eso nos lleva a pensar que quizás
muchos fenómenos que consideramos
ciertos y en los cuales basamos nuestras
prácticas podrían no serlo y tal vez eso
tenía que ver con la forma en la que
venimos haciendo ciencia entonces
empezamos un proceso de revisar nuestras
prácticas científicas que todavía hoy
continúa
si queremos mejorar el mundo necesitamos
entenderlo y eso sólo es posible con
información confiable necesitamos que
los estudios son repetibles que las
recetas estén completas y disponibles y
que el proceso sea transparente
necesitamos abrir la ciencia
yo soy psicóloga y trabajo haciendo
investigación y comunicación pública de
la ciencia pero sé relativamente poco
entendí algo que me cambió mi forma de
ver esto que hago y es que a diferencia
de lo que nos enseñan en la escuela les
hice no es el método científico la
ciencia tiene un método varios en
realidad pero no es eso de ciencia es
una actividad social hechas por humanos
que los humanos cometemos errores
tenemos intereses necesitamos dinero
para vivir dependemos de las
instituciones que nos financian o que no
nos financian nos peleamos nos amigamos
además la ciencia tiene ciertos valores
ciertos ideales que la hacen distinta de
otras formas de conocimiento quienes
hacemos ciencia sabemos que no podemos
acceder a la realidad de forma directa
pero si podemos inventar formas para
acercarnos a ella y armar una especie de
mapa para entenderla ya que tenemos una
clave
de todo esto es para asumir que una
explicación de un pedacito del mundo
funciona
necesitamos pruebas y la posibilidad de
revisar el proceso para evaluar qué tan
confiables son esas pruebas
no importa quién lo diga y qué tan
bonita sea una explicación la actitud
científica consiste en fortalecer o
debilitar nuestras creencias según le
bien se disponible y esto sólo es
posible en colaboración necesitamos
intercambiar ideas criticarnos pelearnos
unir fuerzas
reconoce unos humanos no es menor porque
nos ayuda a entender por qué y cómo
llegamos a esta situación pero
entendernos humanos también significa
saber que podemos reflexionar que
podemos colaborar y podemos crear
soluciones hace poco hace unos días
descubrí una aplicación para el celular
para pasar menos tiempo en las redes
sociales no porque me falta a mí
y me quedé pensando en por qué esas
aplicaciones funcionan y es porque en
vez de basarse en un ideal se basan en
entender cómo funcionamos si la voluntad
no alcanza entonces podemos inventar
formas para ayudarla por supuesto que la
intención es importante pero muchas
veces no es suficiente entonces
entendiendo a los humanos y tomando los
ideales de la ciencia como horizonte
empezamos a repensarlo todos las teorías
las metodologías las formas de publicar
nuestros estudios científicos quiénes
cómo y dónde estamos haciendo ciencia
quiénes están adentro y quiénes se están
quedando afuera
a cada problema que encontramos tratamos
de inventar una solución por ejemplo si
resulta que
vamos de nuevo con esta parte porque no
sabía si esperar
si resulta que recetas que se pierden o
no están disponibles
creamos repositorios abiertos gratuitos
donde podemos ir depositando y poniendo
a disposición todo lo que hacemos los
materiales los recursos los resultados
para que otras personas puedan revisarlo
pero también para que otras personas
puedan usarlo para crear nuevo
conocimiento y esta forma hacemos que la
ciencia sea más eficiente si resulta que
algunos países que concentran más
recursos o hacen más estudios sobre un
tema creamos asociaciones
internacionales para hacer estudios en
colaboración entre muchos países y
aprovecho la mejor esos recursos y
esfuerzos en psicología si hay estudios
que han involucrado a más de 100
laboratorios colaborando
si lo que queremos es entender mejor el
mundo abrir las ciencias solamente entre
quienes hacemos investigación no es
suficiente si queremos conocer las
recetas que nos faltan los ingredientes
que nos faltan en las recetas
necesitamos también involucrar a otras
personas
y me gusta pensar a la ciencia como la
cultura está en todas partes influyen
muchas cosas de nuestra vida y todos
podemos contribuir aunque solo algunas
personas lo hagan de manera profesional
la cultura es de todos y para todos la
ciencia también por eso la ciencia ha
abierto busque crear y fortalecer
herramientas y mecanismos para que todas
las personas sepan qué se está haciendo
puedan participar del proceso e
involucrarse se trata de abrir la
ciencia y hacerla permeable para poder
pensar otras preguntas y también pensar
otras posibles respuestas
hay otra ciencia posible una ciencia
donde las recetas estén disponibles y
las tartas de manzana tengan el sabor
que tienen que tener una ciencia abierta
colaborativa diversa
como investigador es para mí fundamental
participar del proceso no dejar que
otras personas decidan la ciencia del
futuro sino involucrarme aportar mi
mirada sumar mi voz como comunicadores
de la ciencia pienso en la importancia
de incluir estos cambios a la hora de
contar estudios y resultados sobre todo
incluyendo el proceso humano sin el cual
es imposible pensar a la ciencia y como
ciudadana me entusiasma la idea de poder
que podamos participar en esas ciencias
que nos gustan aunque no tengamos un
título en ellas o no estemos
especialistas en ellas que seamos parte
de esas ciencias que son parte de
nosotros
la forma de hacer ciencia que está
cambiando y a mí me encanta
las nuevas generaciones van a tener
otros estándares y otras prácticas para
entender mejor este mundo extraño y
maravilloso que nos rodea
colaborando de distintas partes del
mundo incluyendo voces de toda la
sociedad
es que
la ciencia es por definición abierta
pero parece que en alguna parte del
camino nos olvidamos ahora de a poco si
hacemos las cosas bien es posible decir
que la ciencia del futuro será abierta o
no será gracias
[Aplausos]
a
[Música]